hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba look
who it is with me today Rachel Cushing
you could follow her at Twitter at
Rachel J King she is a lovely lovely
woman who kicks major ass in the Schmo
down I'll admit she's not as talented as
me in the Schmo down I have like a 1 in
5 streak I've only lost one match Wow
we're like my Rachel Eco on the channel
for a while now cuz she is a smart
cookie this one we're gonna watch the
trailer today for the vanishing of
Sydney Hall and I might as well give a
patron of the day shout out to the
patron who co-wrote this movie Jason
Dolan Jason Dylan's been in this
apartment he's a really nice guy he's
the networking kind of guy he's that guy
yeah he's a Hollywood guy you put him in
a room and he will talk business with ya
now because I know you Jason I cannot do
the thing where I have to only talk good
about the movie in fact I'm gonna go the
complete opposite I'm only gonna point
out the negatives I see in this trailer
you can point out some I'll be nice you
can be nice but I don't want to seem
like I'm you playing favoritism here you
know or feeling pressure to say kind
things about something Dylan O'Brien's
lesser twin Logan Lerman a great actor
I'm just messing with you because people
always compare them alright Mantha Logan
Lerman fanbase they pissed at me right
now joking yes for the section books he
takes out a can of lighter fluid
I know why he'd burn aliens why because
he wrote them a 24 they make good deed
or well the best friends right time I've
been searching for him for years sending
us one of our brightest students because
brilliant
what if I wrote now what would it be
about Sooni melody no no I need to keep
running away from me because it's fun
[Music]
even number one on the bestseller list
for eight months I'm seeing there she
write about me and you know my father is
doesn't mean I should write a book about
you'll be singing a different tune
tomorrow what happens tomorrow this book
is a dangerous sign of the times
I don't know what he wants he knows
everything about me not one is claimed
to see or hear from Sydney all over five
years now how is that possible
every weird asthma with me beginning to
a great book I don't know what is
[Music]
the entire course of a person's life can
change milliseconds
[Music]
this is do you think
[Music]
give me the information about Sydney
home
you'll never see me again
[Music]
interesting interesting okay surprise
this is a January movie yeah that's
probably the only theater she has me
concerned immediate I'd be good I
thought the first half of the trailer
was really really intriguing
it's wordy but it did a good job setting
up the idea of Kyle Chandler you know
being fairly obsessed with this story
and those are I find always good movies
well yeah they're on the scent of
something and trying to unravel the
mystery so I wonder if it'll be one of
those movies where it jumps around in
time I was kind of confused on where the
focus is coming from because it starts
off with Kyle Chandler and the cow
Chandler it seems like it's taking it
from the perspective of him and then the
last half of the trailer seemed like
it's all from Logan Lerman perspective
kind of forgot Kyle Chandler's in the
movies I'm wondering who's the one
narrating this story whose specific
perspective are we seeing all this take
place from because I like the approach
more of going from Kyle Chandler's
character yeah and then letting the
mystery unravel as opposed to taking it
just from Logan Luhrmann's perspective
and we kind of just get all the
information fed to us because I'd like
to get to know keep asking myself who
was Sydney Hall and I felt like the last
time that I ever started getting a
better idea of who he is I'm like I kind
of don't want that through the trailer
right now that's the thing the trailers
right is it that that give and take of
you want a certain amount to get you
interested and you want to go see the
movie but I mean most of the time you
find that they give you a little more
than you want yeah it's the deep their
default is to assume that you want more
information plus despite your earlier
comments logan lerman is quite the draw
and genuinely think logan lerman is
awesome but it would it would be a
reason for a lot of Anna stare I say
younger viewers would want to know that
he's a big part of the movie yeah I want
to go see it personally I'm clearly more
interested in Kyle Chandler coach I
liked the the sort of mystery feel to it
I think that there's a look like a lot
of interesting people popping up to it
like Nathan Lane and Tim
Nelson and Elle Fanning looks like to be
playing a pretty big part aha yeah and
the kid from Glee
ooh what's his name like Jenner wow you
know his name should I cut out that
Logan garment I was just making a joke
because I know people always compare
what I think this movie could do for
really interesting marketing is really
Sydney halls novel definitely have an
actual novel it was a part of me to do a
true story or is this actually just a
work of fiction within a work of fiction
yeah I think that's probably more likely
the case probably the case because I
like that concept alone this guy who
creates something that's a book it's so
contrary to burn yeah I was very touchy
so and then he vanishes it's on the
mystery up for this guy because he's
actually an important figure at this
point because that book must have been
very meaningful in some way or had some
soft strong solid points yeah you making
me want to read the book yeah I think
the writers the screenwriters Jason
Dolan novel and then release it to the
public is a special little intriguing
thing to have and also it's a 24 and a
24 makes some pretty big films I'm
really concerned about my Logan Lerman
comment should I cut it out could be
talking about should I cut out my you
know do I have to list every logan
lerman performance I really like I think
it looks like a good movie really my
only concern is why they push why is
this a January release because it seems
like a kind of movie that could have
come out like in a fall time or even a
little bit before summer so when they
push the movie to January I'm like is
gonna be good is it gonna be bad I mean
Jason Dolan wrote it so must be great it
must be amazing I hope you'll cast me
after the great comments I made in this
video you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects you can click that notification
about get notified every time one of our
videos is up follow Rachel Jay cooking
on Rachel Jay cooking Twitter handle is
their name I said that was send this all
in Reverse I think they got it though
let's hope so the internet people are a
little slow
too quick to judge but a little slow